all right guys we're back uh vegas was
awesome first of all i just want to say
thank you uh so much to uh scooter and
manson y'all were great taking care of
us and seeing that was very
inspirational it was awesome you know
how they say like uh what is that [ __ ]
where they take kids from the hood and
they make them go to rich neighborhoods
what is that [ __ ] like fresh air fund or
something like that fresh air they like
to take you to the country or whatever
yeah but like even busing and that kind
of stuff it's important
not in terms of the schooling but being
able to see things because once you see
something it becomes a reality better
example lebron giving everybody his
school a bike so you can just go explore
yeah
yeah i think they got all this other
[ __ ] tied to it but just going taking a
bike and just riding it and seeing it
like
people have huge houses like this that's
a possibility yes exactly and who knows
if they'll actually go it's almost good
to like force them but like seeing
something
like seeing bts perform in a stadium for
80 000 people and like how they
engineered the show and all this kind of
stuff it like really inspired me i'm
like okay how do you do comedy in a
place like this
and before that i didn't even think of
doing comedy and well maybe early on but
i thought i was doing comedy and
stadiums but still it's just like
yeah you got to see it
you got to see these things and i'm a
[ __ ] dreamer dude i dream crazy yeah
but
being able to see it makes it so much
more accessible like the problem just
starts to solve itself once you see it
anyway um but yeah shout outs to them
man thank you that weekend was [ __ ]
awesome or those 15 hours were great
uh okay what else we got man uh
interesting thing happened with this kid
he's a uh streamer his name is uh speed
yeah i show speed yeah
boy
yeah what'd you say it's a wild boy wild
kid he's a kid he's you know he's i
think 16 17 years old and uh he got
knocked off twitch and i think he's also
being suspended from youtube as well or
what yeah yeah that's what it looks like
and he's like banned from valerian and
like other like games specifically right
so like he's not allowed on those game
servers right now right and then could
potentially just be wiped off stream all
together and
so he's this kid who said some pretty
crazy things in stream he's also done a
lot of hilarious stuff yeah you know and
uh yeah he's tricky because like he's
undeniably talented as a streamer
without a doubt especially at like 17 he
talks to a million people every day on
stream like and streaming engaging hard
bruh wild yeah you got to constantly
entertain just by yourself just like
radio show host yeah 17 like crazy
you're almost incentivized to be crazy
and say well it's [ __ ] exactly you've
got to keep things moving exactly and
then the issue is that he goes on stream
and just says crazy stuff at like 17
doesn't necessarily have like a boundary
and then just says [ __ ] that's like at
17 you're not or 16 you're not thinking
about the rest of your life yeah right
you're not thinking okay how am i going
to feed my family how am i going to take
care of my kids these type of things
he's 17 years old he's probably making
millions of dollars and he made those
millions of dollars by saying the
wildest [ __ ] in the moment and people
just [ __ ] lose their minds it's also
hard to tell if it's a joke or not like
sometimes he's doing [ __ ] that's a joke
like he'll do like the dick suck thing
oh that's funny he's doing that to be
crazy yeah but then other times he'll
just be on this crazy screaming rant and
it's like is this a joke or you actually
like this and then that [ __ ] is like
kind of inexcusable yeah it's just i
just feel bad because it's obvious that
he doesn't have anybody in his corner
kind of giving him gain
and because it's such a new world how
can somebody give you game on streaming
when streaming is less than 10 years old
or whatever yeah but usually like with
money comes
people who can help you make more money
yeah that's because they see that they
can make some themselves and there's
good money in stream
there's good money in stream 100 and a
lot of these people are becoming famous
and successful and
it's just unfortunate man it's yeah this
is one of those things that kind of
makes me sad yeah you know because he
needs a mentor say again he needs a
minute he needs a mentor he needs
someone to be like yo
if you say these things you are
cancelled yeah and he's operating in the
streaming space where and i'm not trying
to cap for him but like if you're
playing video games with people
everything's anonymous except when
you're streaming with your face but the
way people speak to you over video games
is how someone would speak if they were
anonymous yeah that's crazy [ __ ] you
racist [ __ ] sexist [ __ ] the [ __ ] he's
saying there's probably mad people
listening right now that said all the
same [ __ ] when they were 16 or similar
things when they were 16. but they just
didn't have a camera in their face yeah
with a million people watching which is
still saying it now yeah there's not a
camera
100
so he's in this environment where all
this like for lack of a better word like
toxicity exists yeah like and people get
charged up when they're competitive like
if we're gonna look at gaming
like we look at sports
right it's an esport right now right you
don't think that basketball players are
saying wild [ __ ] to each other on the
[ __ ] court now imagine they're not
even they don't even have to see each
other there's not even a risk of
fighting exactly now how crazy football
players saying the craziest [ __ ] to one
another like to the point where when one
of them is mic'd up they gotta give each
other nods they should be like oh chose
hill i'm miked up don't say that crazy
[ __ ] so
this is a sport and people are operating
in a way
that they do when they're playing a
competitive thing yeah now i'm not
justifying what he said what he said is
gonna be [ __ ] up because you're
looking at it as pure entertainment but
when you're looking at you just in a
boxing ring with someone you don't think
floyd is saying the craziest [ __ ] to
canelo when they're fighting yeah like
so i get especially in that environment
why they think it's acceptable to say
these wild things especially if you've
been rewarded with millions of dollars
and millions of fans yeah but like those
are like competitive by nature and like
the whole point is to try to beat each
other whereas like an e date or like
you're on stream just talking with
people like it's not well i'm
specifically talking about the video
game that he got kicked out from oh i
got you also even when any time he's
streaming he is doing his job as an
entertainer and the thing about being 17
especially a boy you don't understand
consequences yeah because you haven't
had to deal with real consequences do
you want to show the clip that uh got
him kicked off youtube yeah youtube clip
yeah yeah the the clip that got him
kicked off of twitch is is wild
yeah i don't even wanna play that on
flight yeah i don't even wanna play and
it sucks uh because it's harder for
black streamers to grow their audience
and it's like he was growing at a crazy
rate why is it harder for them i don't
know i just like they
say it's harder and i believe them oh
yeah
do you know what
i don't know what that would be
because they can't say the n word is
freely
i mean i think that's probably it yeah
but yeah this is the clip that is going
around now that got him banned from like
valor and a bunch of other she is she's
on top of the thing
10 seconds
calm down damn bruh shut up bro i know
how to play this game i'm not a noob all
right
talking to me right now it's a [ __ ]
female
get off the [ __ ] game and do your
whipping dishes [ __ ] shut up [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is wrong with y'all stop talking to
me like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] this wrong child dog i'm not one of
these little lame man's battling nerves
they get two kids
so like
he's an engaging streamer bro like
imagine you're fifteen
that was hilarious bro i'm sorry
i laughed you know what's great is when
a black guy calls a white guy a monkey
takes all the racial tension out of it
and it just becomes awesome laugh at how
funny it is
[Music]
get the [ __ ] off stream and do your
husband's dishes [ __ ] that is crazy
but hilarious
i'm sorry it made me laugh
what am i supposed to say oh my god that
didn't make you laugh
y'all didn't have to stop yourselves
from laughing when we were watching that
i wasn't laughing i'm not one of those
guys
stop podcasting go do your wife's dishes
it's a funny thing to say you know
what's crazy it's only sexist because of
uh the role the gender roles of of women
doing their husbands dishes but just
telling somebody to do their spouse's
dishes is hilarious yeah like me telling
you but that's the only reason that's
what i say is because it's a girl yeah
yeah no but like it's only racist
because he's a black guy when you say
the racist thing
i'm saying it's the same thing
y'all don't understand what i'm trying
to say
what am i saying you're saying it's a
funny insult in general if you just said
it to anybody it's funny you just can't
say i don't know
yeah but you should say it to any guy
all the time i guess what i'm saying
it's like women don't do dishes anymore
yeah like that's not their role in
society is to only do dishes so we're
using antiquated gender roles like
they're 16 they're all playing video 16.
that 16 year old girl grew up with her
mom and dad both working not one of them
was just doing the dishes
she might not even understand it
i think she understands okay maybe she
understands
it's like go go go shine your your your
husband's armor
yeah did you say eventually that is
going to become that yeah eventually no
that's a large gas
okay so what is the takeaway with speed
here
like one he's doing things that are like
inappropriate like he's yelling at
people like on a game that he doesn't
necessarily i'm assuming he doesn't know
them but if he knows her and like
they're friends you can get away with
saying different things i'm assuming
he's just yelling crazy on a stream
come on now come on
he'd be
but what he's saying is wrong by the
same time he's like a super entertaining
experience he's engaging he's he's
engaging and like he's also funny he
puts the gay and engaging yeah
but he's like he's a great streamer
stream is hard like i said before and
he's no good go do your wife's dishes
bro
go do your wife's
dishes a mentor he needs someone to help
him he does he does he needs someone to
come in and say yo here's how you got to
behave now that you're making probably a
hundred thousand dollars a year like
changing people's lives like yeah
there's a ton of attention and spotlight
on someone the 17 without really any
infrastructure yeah that's just [ __ ]
hard and that's the tricky thing about
streaming is you don't need any
infrastructure so a 17 year old kid can
become uber famous yeah and there's also
no censoring like if you get tick tock
famous you can make a tick tock be like
i don't really like that yeah like you
don't have to post it when you're
streaming it's all posted yeah
it's insanely high stakes and that's why
people are watching yeah
yeah he's he's on the highest high wire
because he's saying the craziest [ __ ]
yeah no censorship no post like editing
nothing
that's crazy dog yeah and he's gonna
stick around like as long as they're
streaming around like
what are you saying that come on bro
did you laugh
what is it absolutely not
i've never allowed this sexism ever yeah
yeah
i laughed the hardest thing
it's not sexist it's not sexist yeah
it's an activity watching dishes is an
activity both sexes can do it yeah if
she said if she wasn't a woman it
wouldn't be you know it would be more
offensive go when i said to akash
should be a bicycle
i love that video but but yeah it's not
sexist i stand by it's not sexist it's
an activity anybody can wash dishes
women are better
they're closer to the sink
yeah
yeah it's like it's i have to bend over
too much too
you don't have longer arms you say again
yeah you only got longer arms i'm still
too tall
yeah i'm way too tall but you could do
it you could you could uh you could
probably do it i go watch my wife yeah
you can wash your wife's dishes bro yo
go wash your wife's dishes is crazy
right that's [ __ ]
pure
you know egalitarian or something what
would you tell speed if he was sitting
here right now watching
um
i i tell him
hey buddy that [ __ ] was [ __ ] killed
i don't know what to tell you it sucks
when you get canceled off some [ __ ] that
absolutely murders the room
and uh there are other videos out there
that you're saying wild [ __ ] that is
like a little bit uncomfortable cut that
[ __ ] out and maybe if those videos
didn't exist this one wouldn't be that
big a deal my my feeling is his other
video which we won't play is absolutely
wild and
and taps into sexism
yeah so now everybody's primed to look
for sexism yeah if that video didn't
exist nobody's looking for and people go
ah that's a sexist thing that's a sexist
joke you should have made that section
joke but when you compare the two
incredibly tame
i don't think this is that bad
this is tame compared to the other one
yeah objectively especially on a video
game app go to wash dishes like do we
know what these kids are saying to each
other n-word is like i'm not gonna
defend everything this kid said because
again we saw that other videos [ __ ]
crazy but yes objectively
go wash your husband's dishes one time
that's it one joke yeah this is this is
his apology what's good um everybody um
it's a clip you know that i've seen you
know that's going crazy right now uh me
between the altercation with uh a girl
and i was playing volleyball
you know what i'm saying and i want to
say some you know like a few things um
from that uh situation you know what i'm
saying but that day um you know
i wasn't having a good day you know i
was getting a lot of racist takes of
speech donations a lot of people you
know talking about my dead aunt
right now but look i don't want to make
that no excuse i'm wrong you know what
i'm saying i'm not i'm not trying to
justify you know what i'm saying
i'm just saying like that day i just
don't bash on people for no reason
that's why that's where i'm coming from
from that you know statement i just said
but you know i'm i'm completely wrong
you know what i'm saying i was
completely wrong in that situation right
there i can't say anything to justify
that situation right there but that clip
is from months ago and i changed from
now and i grew you know what i'm saying
i'm very i'm i don't want to say i'm
young you know what i'm saying i'm very
young
i for every situation i grow you know
and i change you know and i got to
become a better person that is not me no
more that is not me and i grow from that
situation that's come from the bottom of
my heart i doubt it that is not me you
know hopefully i can you know really you
know see like the genuine enemy you know
what i'm saying
i apologize from that girl i
apologize to me up and say anything you
know i would love to hear her out you
know what i'm saying but you know
i apologize that's not me that [ __ ] is
from months ago i'm sorry man peace out
you're so disappointed
bro i i needed him to like say peace out
leave the stream going and he doesn't
realize it's still gone exactly yeah i
thought that this was about to be a
prank and that'd be legendary [ __ ] no
that that would be great yeah this was
i was getting racist donations it's just
like well you know yeah you don't have
to accept do you have to accept them
yeah like if they donate it he has a
feature where like if you donate it
autoplays a message that you send
so people would be like yo here's five
bucks
really
that's funny dude what a bargain to call
black person the n-word right if you're
a racist
if you're a racist dude like get on
twitter that's how it is oh my that's
what they've done now he hadn't turned
the feature off by now i mean you get
paid from it yeah but as i'm saying you
named your price
there you go that means yeah i can feel
bad for you if you named your price
that's how i'm assuming is i don't know
if i say
1000 you'll be as racist to me as you
want to
i don't get to be like you know i should
hurt my feelings i got a thousand
dollars
you